if you happen to hear your angry uncle
banging his head against a shed earlier
it's because tonight at the DNC Hillary
Clinton officially accepted her historic
nomination for president Jack roll the
clip
prepare for Game of Thrones pun I can't
believe she still hasn't gotten in
trouble for bran Ghazi oh you guys I
know so long ago and add insult to
injury for the GOP she ended her speech
by pouring wine on Carly fiorina's face
but hey Bernie Sanders seems to be
taking it well
when he hit the ground he actually
shattered into a pile of Werther's
Originals radians now that Hillary has
claimed the dim throne what's a good
slogan for Hillary House up House
Clinton first of her name Mike Birbiglia
go it'd be like a bumper sticker it says
like Hillary Clinton you guys remember
when Obama hugged me Gillian Jacobs who
was struggling with her voice
Hillary literally the only option today
she couldn't talk and then I realized
she just doesn't want to talk to me
that's so weird everyone I meet doesn't
have a voice Tammy
Hillary breaking glass ceilings since
before Trump's third wife was born yes